every parent witnesses the metamorphosis
of their baby's voice from cries to
babbles and finally words this process
is dependent on the physical growth of
vocal structures and social feedback the
way we develop vocalizations was thought
to be unique among primates in fact for
decades we believe that the closest
corollary was bird songs recently
researchers monitored the calls of baby
marmosets from birth to two months they
found that like humans marmoset
communication is influenced by vocal
structure growth but they observed a lot
of variability in the timing of when
this transition occurs that can't be
explained by growth alone using parental
interaction experiments their study
shows that baby marmoset vocal
development is influenced by parental
feedback when a baby marmoset makes a
more mature like sound the parent
responds
similarly reinforcing the development of
that call
so it turns out we're not the only
primates who learn to communicate by
being talked to
oh yeah